back to the movies
i can't wait to go to the movies again
my wife cheryl and i that's been our
date
for you know since we were in high
school so we missed that
a lot it's a bonding experience to have
a story that's
shared we want to sit together in the
dark and and feel each other
gasp or laugh i'm a big movie consumer
my dirty little secret is that i bring
my own
well at cinemark theaters you'll still
be able to get popcorn but you won't be
able to butter it yourself
refills on drinks require a new cup
there's social distance markers like
these
and lots of hand sanitizer stations what
are you doing to make people feel
safe and want to come back to theaters
every morning
first thing we do is we come we spray
every seat with
a device that actually kills the covid
germs
in between the shows we can wipe down
every seat as well so
the entire place is cleaned this is a
clean of environment you're going to get
anywhere
we're limiting our capacity to 50 how
close will people
sit to other people they don't know we
put together a ticketing technology so
if you and a friend bought those two
seats the two on the left and the two on
the right are going to be blocked out
next to you
cashless ticket purchasing and spacing
out shows to minimize crowds are some of
the ways theater owners are keeping us
safe
and if you want to see james bond wonder
woman or black widow on the big screen
it's good to see it too sis it's
required that you wear a face mask
just like tom cruise did when he
attended a screening in london
[Applause]
everybody everyone has agreed to these
standards we've got medical experts and
disease control experts suggest them
theaters across the country have agreed
to cinema safe
when do you think new york and la will
reopen probably somewhere in the next
30 to 60 days cinemark is also doing
something
interesting if you want to buy a theater
because in the past a lot of stars would
do that
now anybody can live that star life we
call it a private watch party
so you and 19 friends can come and
basically
lease out one of our theaters it'll
range from 99 to that library product
to 149 for first run and you own the
theater you can bring
your crew your trusted group and you've
got it for 20 people or less for
100 bucks
[Music]